BUYLEESA.COM TODAY. YOU NEED
THIS BED.
>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR FINAL
EXAM, OUR CUTTHROAT COMPETITION
WHEN WE DECIDE WHICH NEWS
PERSONALITY IS PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION.
AT THIS YEAR'S CHAMPION IS CHRIS
JENKINS, TEMPORARILY CRIPPLED IN
AN A MISHAP.
HE'S BEEN CHALLENGED BY KRISTEN
FISHER.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE TAKING ON A
BUZZER SHOW WITH A ONE ARMED
MAN?
>> AND I WANTED YOU TO KNOW THAT
I DIDN'T WANT MY VICTORY TO BE
MARKED WITH AN ASTERISK, SO I
WILL RUN MY OWN LITTLE SLING
HERE.
>> SHE KNOWS MY SECRET, I'M VERY
INTIMIDATED.
>> Tucker: ALL YOU HAVE TO SAY
IS, CHRIS JENKINS.
>> NORMALLY I WOULD SAY HAND ON
BUZZERS.
>> MADE THE BEST SLING WIN.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
I ASKED THE QUESTIONS, FIRST ONE
TO BUZZ AND GET TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION AND YOU MUST WAIT UNTIL
I COMPLETE THE QUESTION TO
ANSWER.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> I'M READY.
>> AMERICAN AIRLINES EXPANDING
ITS CRACKDOWN ON EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMALS, FERRETS AND
HEDGEHOGS UNFORTUNATELY ARE NO
LONGER WELCOME ON BOARD AMERICAN
FLIGHTS.
WHICH KIND OF ANIMAL HAS ALSO
BEEN BANNED?
PARENTS, GOATS OR MINIATURE
PONIES?
[BUZZER]
GRIFF JENKINS.
>> GOATS.
>> IS AT GOATS?
STARTING IN JULY
AMERICAN AIRLINES WILL BAN
FERRETS.
AND GOATS.
[GOATS BLEEDING]
>> Tucker: QUESTION NUMBER
TWO.
THE AMERICAN BRIDE HAS LEARNED
ALL ABOUT T ETIQUETTE.
T AND GREAT BRITAIN MUST BE
STARTED IN A SPECIFIC DIRECTION.
IS IT CLOCKWISE,
COUNTERCLOCKWISE, OR 12-6, 12-6?
CHRISTIAN         KRISTIN FISHER
CHRISTIAN         KRISTIN FISHE.
>> COUNTERCLOCKWISE.
>> Tucker: LET'S ROLL THE
TAPE.
>> WHEN WE START, WE NEVER WANT
TO STIR CLOCKWISE OR
COUNTERCLOCKWISE.
IT'S ACTUALLY JUST 12-6, 12-6.
>> I HAD NO IDEA.
>> DOES THIS PLAY A PART?
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
A T-SHIRT BEING SOLD BY THE GAP
IS BEING RECALLED AND DESTROYED
BECAUSE IT APPARENTLY SHOWS AN
ERRONEOUS MAP OF WHICH ASIAN
COUNTRY?
>> TAIWAN.
>> CHINA, IT LEAVES OFF TAIWAN.
>> Tucker: ROLL TAPE.
>> THE GAP HAS CREATED AN
INTERNATIONAL UPROAR.
THE COMPANY ISSUED AN APOLOGY
AND PULLED A T-SHIRT FEATURING
AN INCORRECT MAP OF CHINA.
NOW, I WOULD LIKE THE GAP TO
APOLOGIZE TO ME FOR WHAT THEY
CONSIDER A MAN'S MEDIUM.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S THE GAP?
SO CHINA, TAIWAN.
THAT IS CORRECT, YOU ARE BACK TO
POWER.
QUESTION FOUR, PARANORMAL
ACTIVITY UNDERWAY IN MICHIGAN.
A MAN THERE SAYS HIS MOTION
SENSOR SECURITY CAMERA CAPTURE
THE IMAGE OF A CELESTIAL BEING
HOVERING ABOVE HIS TRUCK.
WHAT WAS FLOATING ABOUT THE
MAN'S VEHICLE?
GRIFF JENKINS.
>> AND ANGEL.
>> Tucker: IS THAT TRUE?
ROLL TAPE.
>> TAKE A GOOD LOOK.
MANY, INCLUDING THEIR PASTOR, SO
THEY BELIEVE THIS IMAGE CAPTURED
BY A SECURITY CAMERA SHOWS AN
ANGEL HOVERING OVER THE FAMILY
STRUCK LAST WEEK.
SO, COULD IT BE?
>> THE PHOTOS OF ARE EXACTLY HOW
THEY WERE TAKEN.
I CHOOSE TO BELIEVE IT.
>> BUT WHAT WAS IT REALLY?
>> Tucker: WE DON'T ADDRESS
THAT, WE ARE DEALING WITH
METAPHYSICS HERE.
FINAL QUESTION, ARGUABLY THE
STORY OF THE WEEK.
THE AUDIO HAS PEOPLE SCRATCHING
THEIR HEADS.
THEY CAN'T TELL WHETHER THE
VOICE IN THE CLIP IS SAYING THE
WORD YANNY OR THE WORD LAUREL?
TO DATE, IT HAS BEEN SETTLED.
WHAT IS THE ACTUAL WORD ON THE
FLIP?
GRIFF JENKINS.
>> LAUREL.
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD.
>> THAT'S A RECORDING OF THE
WORD LAUREL FROM A WEBSITE
CALLED VOCABULARY.COM.
THE BRAIN INTERPRETS WHAT THEY
ARE HEARING AND THEN IT IS
DISTURBED, CAUSING SOME PEOPLE
TO HEAR ANOTHER FREQUENCY AND
HEAR THE WORD, YANNY.
>> CORRECT.
>> Tucker: I WAS ROOTING FOR
YOU.
GRIFF JENKINS, CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU ARE ROLLING THROUGH HERE AND
AGAIN, THE ERIC WEMPLE MUG IS
YOUR PRIZE.
>> THANK YOU.
MAKE SURE YOU COME BACK.